Lucas webinar is a student at one of
Germany's best schools of chemistry the
RW th in Aachen his physical chemistry
lecture starts at 8:15
now that I'm into it some things are
really interesting other things are
tough I'm in the fourth semester and I
have to aim for my bachelor's then I can
go for my masters
that's obligatory in the Natural
Sciences a PhD is to actually the
motivation is there you can invent new
things and do research and that's fun
his studies will last eight years eight
years of learning formulas once the
lecture is over he cycles off to his
internship after sitting for an hour and
a half in a lecture it's really nice to
ride my bike a little at ten o'clock
Lucas takes time to go over the
theoretical material from the morning's
lecture the students help each other
where they can
if there's something I don't understand
I always ask my fellow students first
then maybe a professor chemistry may
help stave off the looming oil shortage
chemicals can be used to extract crude
oil from bedrock in a process called
fracking critics say that damages the
environment how does Lucas see it I try
to improve the process so it doesn't
cause environmental problems just find
other possibilities one of his
instructors is researching a way to make
biofuel from waste wood federal
government funding supports the research
lucas has gradually found his way to a
focus for his studies macro chemistry
that would qualify him for a job where
he could one day help to develop a
biofuel suitable for mass production
lunch break is short lucas is one of
about twelve hundred chemistry students
here at 2:30 he takes an oral exam right
there in the hallway the instructor asks
the students to recite formulas now it's
Lucas's turn DP after DT Delta equals
Delta s Delta s I can't think of it
right now he didn't know the answer now
he's worried about his grade I found
that really difficult he was okay it
could have been better it was better
than my last test but it was the
second-best grade second best 4 p.m.
some mechanical engineering students
have adapted an engine to run on the
fuel the chemistry students developed
from waste wood it's definitely exciting
now we have an area of application we
can work on directly now we can work on
our fuel and see what we're doing this
for now we have a goal we can work
towards at 5:00 p.m. he goes home but
his day still isn't over now he and a
fellow student hit the books usually
till late into the night